pro tip if you're gonna hold Tyree kill
it really hold more yeah better you
better tackle a big account they tried
but that wasn't enough to slow down
Tyree kill the Kansas City Chiefs
offense if you're watching on TV you
know what we're talking about if you're
listening on NBC sports radio Tyree kill
was held blatantly on what ended up
being the sixth and final touchdown pass
for Patrick mahomes on Sunday the
Pittsburgher didn't matter Tyree killed
still caught the ball and scored pad
from Holmes becomes the youngest player
in NFL history to throw six touchdown
passes in a game also sets the all-time
record with 10 in the first to nobody in
the history of the National Football
League has thrown for 10 touchdown
passes in the first two games of a
season
or should I say had thrown 10 before
yesterday when mahomes added 6 to his
four from last week
Texas education how much is 6 and 4/10
Jerry though the Chiefs
carried by Patrick mahomes and all their
other weapons it's not just my homes
it's all the other weapons and the ball
was spread around aggressively yesterday
Sammy Watkins had a big game Tyree
killed did what he does Travis Kelce had
a big game they ran when they needed to
but they didn't need to Patrick mahomes
incredible as the Chiefs go to 2 and OH
winning at Pittsburgh it looked like it
was gonna be a statement game it ended
up being much closer than it should have
been the Chiefs are up 21 nothing in the
first quarter was the first time the
Steelers were down 21 Oh at home since
December of 1965 playing it pits Stadium
against the Eagles that's how long it
had been since the Steelers without 2100
in the first quarter now in the playoff
game last year against the Jaguars ever
down 20 100 in the second quarter and
we're gonna talk so much about the
dysfunction on the Pittsburgh offense
what the hell is wrong with the
Pittsburgh defense yes I mean that's the
concern up to yesterday you know as much
as everybody piled on Big Ben in week 1
I mean Big Ben was the team yesterday so
that I don't want to hear anybody
discuss that he was impressive but
mahomes
is special there's no other way around
it Mike I mean for a guy at his age to
be doing what he's doing I don't I just
don't know if you can truly quantify it
I mean it's truly amazing to think about
what he is doing setting records
have never been set before in the league
and doing it with I poppin plays - hey I
know he got a few little cheap
touchdowns last week but he's also made
some touchdown throws where we've been
like wow there's only a few guys in the
sport right now that can do that his I
mean you it's almost you can't play his
own defense when you cover the whole
feel right the cheap touchdowns are
gonna come as part of the other day of
knowing right that they can't give you
any area the field so yeah if you go
through your reads hey this guy's gonna
be wide open here in the flat yeah I
think that's really the big thing - Mike
the defending of the whole field is
where you know I don't expect this this
you know roller coaster to stop in
Kansas City because he's a phenomenal
thrower the football down the field
intermediate even the short throws and
Andy Reed and this is why I think we
were so frustrated with the Alex Smith
so the the last few years even down to
the nab when he was in Philadelphia
because there was times where we said
man there was a lot of completions to be
had what's what's there to be had in the
game instead of the bottom stat line and
mahomes is taking advantage of
everything that's there to be had and
more and Andy Reid does make you defend
the whole field it's what run game
Kareem hunt up the middle you know the
speed sweep sideline to sideline defense
has got to run that way so now they're
going horizontal all weight little
slants behind the linebackers okay we
got to worry about that oh and then we
have to worry about 60 and 70 yard bombs
over the top of our head from a guy who
can buy time in the pocket and make
throws that really he's already in a
rarefied class I mean you've been him
you've been watching football there's
not been a lot of guys in this league
history that the ball pops out of the
hand the way it does Patrick my home you
know one of the one of the caveats as it
relates to any quarterback who was just
getting started in his career what
happens after there's enough film out
there to figure out what he's doing and
I don't think it's gonna matter Patrick
mahomes I think he's already at the
point where he understands that offense
it's tailored to a quarterback who is
able to spot before the play what the
coverage is where he's gonna go from
there and I spoke to my home's after the
game and I wanted to know because I'm a
big believer in if you have a guy that
you've taken at the top of the draft put
him on the field and if you don't
believe in that quarterback enough to
put him on the field why are you taking
him
somebody else but my homes explained to
me the benefit of sitting last year he
was able to learn how to learn learn how
to study learn how to prepare learn how
to read those coverages coming out of
the huddle learn how to go through the
progressions in the and Erie defense and
he said if he had played last year he
would have just been winging it yeah and
he wouldn't have a confidence he now has
so this is a prime example and I'm still
a believer in putting the guy on the
field but maybe in this case it all
lines up just right with his arm
strength with the ante read offense the
fact they had Alex Smith last year and
he was learning from somebody good like
Josh Rosen and you're learning in
Arizona I don't think you want him to be
learning the things he's learning by
watching Sam Bradford fair but it worked
out very well last year in the one big
thing that he learned when you're five
and oh you can't get satisfied right now
they're to know he's gonna spend today
his 23rd birthday in the facility all
day studying 49ers film he is not gonna
let up he is driven he is dedicated and
he just turned 23 today it's an amazing
story already and look there's still a
long way to go they got some tough games
coming up beyond the 49ers I have to go
to Denver they play the Patriots they
play the Jaguars we're gonna find out a
lot about this Chiefs team but I mean
there there isn't a much more impressive
task I think then going into Pittsburgh
for their home opener yes and putting v
42 points right on a Steelers defense
that I know that the defense has flaws
but but that is that is a tremendous
outcome and I picked the Chiefs to win
thinking I I'm letting my whole Patrick
mahomes think carry me here because
that's the Steelers we've seen this
movie enough times the Steelers find a
way to win at home especially a home
opener and you got to give credit to the
Chiefs for pulling it off and and and
the question is where does it go from
here it's gonna be fun to watch wherever
ago yeah I didn't think it was I didn't
think he was gonna be capable or the
Kansas City was gonna be capable of
pulling this off I did not I mean yeah
week one road win in LA on the Chargers
Stadium where it was way more Kansas
City fans the Kansas City Chiefs fans
there than charger fans so I was
expecting a few bumps in the road a few
points of confusion for Patrick mahomes
with the blitzberg defense and they
would have something creative but I
think it all goes back to a little bit
what you said to start the the the fear
defenses have already in Kansas of
Kansas City and the fact that they go
wait we literally have to defend every
square inch of this field with this guy
and it takes away the defense's
aggressiveness and what they did
yesterday was Pittsburgh was on their
heels and it was just full attack mode
and mahomes picked them apart it's it's
awesome I mean it really is think of it
this way
the quarterback either puts the defense
on the ropes or the defense puts the
quarterback on the ropes right so what's
mahomes doing he's putting the defense
on the ropes and they do feel like
they're backpedaling and they feel like
nothing we do is only gonna work right
and if we slide this way oh crap this is
open if we slide that way oh crap that
is open and that's where that one year
of watching and learning has helped him
because he told me he he goes up to the
line and he sees the coverage and he
knows based on the coverage what his
first read secondary third reads gonna
be it's not you break the huddle saying
alright this play is designed to go to
Tyree killin if he's covered with throw
to Sammy Watts because if he's covered
we're gonna throw to Travis Kelce no he
comes out and he's smart enough now at
this stage with only three career starts
none at home yes he knows when he walks
up the line of scrimmage what to look
for from working with Andy Reid from
working with Alex Smith and it's working
very well for the chief yes and you know
do you like receivers that are fast yeah
that helps yeah and so I like
quarterbacks for strong arms okay
because that people always say arm
strength it's it's overrated
okay strengths overall so many people
what my report it's also idiots that
listen to your show too that I always
have to defend this even to draft people
because mahomes was my favorite
quarterback in the draft two years ago
oh you just like them because you could
throw it 80 yards yeah yeah I do but you
know Kristin can you play that highlight
package if you it ones once once again I
mean the radio audience funds well
they're gonna they're gonna have
delicious this is where this is where
arm strength is is so successful or so
awesome for an offense I mean whether it
was the post play Kristen if we can ever
get to those two plays yes that's a
broad control
yes but there well I mean that's a
30-yard throw on the rope but then this
plays like this a six yard throw to
Sammy Watkins and people are gonna go
well what's the big deal you know what
the big deal is the ball gets to Sammy
Watkins so quickly that he has a chance
to tuck it and then make the person miss
is what a wide receiver wants to so now
he has time to go BAM I got the ball and
I can make the corner miss one on one
because the ball got on me so fast
instead of it being a bang bang and
those are little things that get lost
sometimes in translation with other
quarterbacks where the Rogers and the
mahomes give their receivers the chance
to do that you know last year when
mahomes was languishing on the bench and
deshaun Watson was a star for the Texans
and Watson was taken to spots after
mahomes yeah draft both the Texans and
the Chiefs traded up to get their
quarterbacks that's when I was saying
hey put my home's on the field when the
Chiefs were going through the law home
we had Travis Kelce on the program last
November and he was talking about all
the incredible things that Patrick
mahomes is doing in practice put him on
the field and you know to his credit
Andy Reid he's not eating that turkey
until it's fully cooked you're right
he's letting he's letting it baste he's
letting it marinate he's letting it cook
and he's letting it just stay - some
would say yes he looks like he was good
at letting things marinate for a
quarterback he gave it that full year
and and now here we go
Patrick mahomes looking very very good
the Steelers defense looking very very
bad and plenty of questions in
Pittsburgh as it relates to where this
team goes from here at oh one and one
that's just a nasty feel for a team that
a lot of people wasn't somebody on this
show picking Super Bowl yes I did I mean
I picked them versus the Saints I'm not
feeling good about either one right now
I'm not gonna totally hit the panic
button in Pittsburgh first of all the
defense played phenomenal in week one I
will and week two yeah it was the Domino
against the brown well let's remember
anyone points to the Browns they let up
a one-yard touchdown run run and lost
the turnover battle by five so they were
put in some very tough positions let's
make sure we've you know don't forget
that also I'll say like yesterday was
not good but
there's not gonna be another offense all
year that they play that's explosive and
dangerous is that Kansas City Chiefs
offense it's still not an excuse I'm not
trying to say that but there is silver
lining what their offense did I mean it
was 21 nothing and me and you were
watching the game together and we
blinked our eyes and all sudden we said
man this game's 2821 and we're gonna
this is fun to watch so there's still a
dangerous football team and they're not
out of this and that's very any of the
Chiefs credits who once they blew their
lead they didn't crater they didn't say
well it's not our day we tried we had
our fun little brother playing big
brother in ping-pong they still put the
pedal to the metal and they got it done
all right another team with a
quarterback that this man did not regard
he's moving up the list he's moving up
he's moved from 70 to 60 two portals the
Jaguars finally trust him and he
delivers we'll explain when PFC life
continues right after this
you
you